what's up everyone james murphy here
from mcoding.io
where i offer live online courses in
python today
we're going to be talking about how to
find primes using the sieve of
eratosthenes
[Music]
so before we can write the sieve of
eratosthenes first we have to understand
what the algorithm is here's the main
idea
you start with a big array let's say we
want all the numbers that are prime
less than 100 then we'd make an array of
length 100
full of booleans the booleans are going
to
tell us whether the number is prime or
not initially
everything is set to true and then we're
going to go through and successfully
mark composite numbers false
so first we start at 2 that's prime
then we take all of the multiples of 2
bigger than 2 of course
and mark them as false because they're
composite
then look through our array and the next
thing that's still marked true
has to be prime that's 3. do the same
thing for 3
mark all of the multiples of 3 that are
bigger than 3 as false
then look at the array again and you'll
see that
5 is the next smallest thing so
let me show you a little graphic from
wikipedia that shows the algorithm in
action
okay so as you can see right now it's
going through marking out all the
multiples of two
then it finds three as the next prime
number it marks out all of those
and then it finds five and then it marks
out all the multiples of five
and then it finds seven then marks out
all the multiples of seven and so on and
so forth
so the idea is go to each number that's
marked true
and mark out all of its multiples as
false
then as you go through the things that
are still marked true
as you go in order up from two
you'll find that all of those things
that are still marked true are primes
okay so now we understand the general
idea of how the algorithm works
let's get into how to actually implement
it in python
so i've already written here just the
definition of the function
we're going to be calling it primes less
than it takes an integer
where i want all of the primes that are
strictly less than that
integer and i wanted to return a list of
integers the primes
so first off let's get rid of some
trivial cases
if n is less than
or equal to two then
well there are no primes less than two
so let's just return
the empty list
otherwise let's make an array
which tells us whether a number is prime
so we're going to have booleans in the
array that are all initially set to true
and i want the length of the array to be
anton so 1 for each
number in our range
then of course i will initially set 0
and 1 to be false so is prime
of 0 is false
and is prime of 1
is also false because 0 and 1 are not
primes
next we go through and start marking out
composite numbers
so we'll go for i in
range of 2 to n
now actually we don't need to go all the
way up to n
because if you have a composite number
then it has at least two factors
and one of those two factors at least
one of them
needs to be less than the square root of
n
so we don't need to check all the way up
to n we only need to check
up to the square root of n so let me
actually change this
i'll go ahead and use the built-in i
square root function
so from math import i square root
to get the smallest or sorry the largest
integer less than the square root of n
so this will allow us to not have to
go all the way up to n but only up to
square root of n so that's going to be
much more efficient
so i'll go through all the numbers from
2
up to the integer square root of my
number
and then i'll check to see if i have a
prime so
if is prime
of i and if so
then i need to mark out all of the
multiples of that number
that are bigger than that number so i'll
say for x
in range now
another optimization that i can do here
is i can actually start at the square
of i and the reason for this is
again if i had a factor that was
less than i then it should have already
been marked out
by the the previous
iteration of the loop so in fact all i
need to do is start out with
the multiples of i that are bigger than
or equal to i
squared so we'll start at i squared
and go to n is the biggest
and if i started i squared which is
multiple of i
and i jump by i each time
then that's going to give me all those
multiples
so just to remember the order of the
arguments here the first one
in range is the starting value the
second is the stopping value
not including that value and then the
third
is the amount to jump by at each step
so i'll go through these and then mark
everything in here as
not prime
then that's basically it i just need to
now return the ones that are still
marked prime at the end of it
so i'll just say return i for
i in range of n
if is prime of i
and if i didn't make any typos that
should be it
so there you have it 2 3 5 7 11 13
17 19 and so on that looks good to me
so there you have it that's how you can
find all the primes less than a certain
number using the sieve of eratosthenes